[Musique]
donc je le dis en tant que femme avait
bel et bien ma mère dans dix ans je sais
pas où je me vois
j'espère je serai plus dans cette
logique parce que sinon j'aurai une
barbe comme ça et j'aurais kader il est
tout ça traduit là l'année prochaine est
ce que je serai encore ces bébés je sais
pas mais je parle on peut toujours être
au gré des stages et un tu sais ya un
moment où trois cdd ça s'arrête
peut-être qu'on trouvera un moyen et
thierry et les stagiaires cdd et cdi je
sais pas du train projet thierry
ardisson la radio et moon journée en
tournage de mount la deuxième saison
avec isabelle nanty rue saint jean
baptiste et puis le week-end prochain
j'ai acheté un appareil à raclette voilà
grosso modo ring road